a furtive great one on a lake of mud at
all beasts with invisible projectiles
tens have never before seen enemies and
pages of untold law the cut content of
blood-borne has finally been laid bare
for us and so to quote Michael ash it is
it about and speak feverishly chatting
till the wee hours of my wonderful night
ok Michael ash come down first the cut
bosses revealed by Zhu Li the witch so
those tentacles clawing at you through
the fog and that's the first sign that
you're not supposed to be here well that
and the doorway to nothingness find you
upon entering your merge onto this muddy
coastline which is very reminiscent of
the orphans arena except this place also
has the sinking architecture of the
chalice dungeon which is really
Lovecraftian if you've read his work and
a few of you may have realized already
what this thing is take a look at its
face it's the moon presence though not
as we know it this form it's in is this
flailing mess of a creature that's
barely capable of standing upright I
think you can even see its heart sort of
hanging loosely below it in this exposed
ribcage it's really weak though you can
see echoes of its former glory when it
lifts itself up off the ground like this
and you know what I think this thing is
I think it might be the physical form of
the moon presence preserved in the
chalice dungeons as opposed to the
consciousness of the moon presence that
we fight in the hunter's dream at the
chalice dungeons after all are home to
the slumbering great ones and some of
these labyrinths are in contact with the
cosmos which allows the great ones to
function and I quote on transcendental
Plains of thought many great ones
ascended long ago and as we know these
beings up above
the nightmares they no longer have a
need for their body in the physical
plane and it would make some sense for
the moon presences physical body to
still be down here but regardless it's
clearly a very undeveloped boss fight
and it's quite easy as a result which
kind of suits its appearance really kind
of like King Allen's
true form in Demon Souls but anyway
speaking of incomplete bosses this
creature currently going by the name
great one beast is this far more agile
monster than many of the other large
bosses you would have fought in
blood-borne and I think it would have
made for a great fight as a result it
has similar moves to SIF and many other
wolf-like enemies in souls and just look
at that face it really reminds me of the
Dragon God from Demon Souls the great
one beast would this have been a great
one that contracted the plague of beasts
or would it be a great one that started
the plague perhaps there's not much else
to say here and lastly a fight with not
one wetness nor two but three wet nurses
Zhu Li who is the chalice dungeons host
they Muse on whether this is an issue
with their illusions spawning but not
going away or whether this was just
meant to be a multi enemy boss fight
it's a bit of a mess either way and
speaking of mirga's wetness after you
defeated her in the main game the
hunter's workshop is set ablaze you
recall well in Germans cut content he
has a very interesting response to this
turn of events we've no need for this
occur see about that flame cleanse this
house of horrors oh he hunters let it be
known we're learning
the end is not far away now
every last dream will burn out and flora
will return from the moon as for us the
time has come to honor her vows hunters
are needed no longer you and I shall
fight to the death and she will consume
the Victor that why we've always said
we'd end it you recall how Lauren's
earth caused you remember there's so
much information here though there is
only really one solid piece of
information we can take from this cut
content in my opinion and it's that the
moon presence is called flora as we had
previously guessed the rest of Germans
cut dialogue is a bit contradictory with
his in-game dialogue first
gomen celebrates the burning of the
workshop stating that hunters are free
free as the wind but in the actual game
gurmann would have remained bound to the
dream even after it burned out which is
evidenced by the fact that the dream
continues even after we take his place
so hunters really free second in the cut
content it seems that Lawrence and
Gherman were originally supposed to
fight fight for the right to be consumed
by flora that's weird
Herman and Lawrence always struck me as
really ambitious characters and look at
what they started and look at what they
achieved in yharnam it doesn't really
fit to me for these old friends to fight
to the death for the right to be eaten I
can see why this might have been cut
what is more in line with German story
is this next bout of dialogue because it
seems that at one point Herman was far
more vocal about his willingness to
leave the nightmare and about what will
happen
when he does what were you thinking if I
die you are to be next what is it you
want from this horrific nightmare what
looking to free me then I graciously
accept forgive me Lawrence in game they
ended up making German far more
reluctant to give up the dream which I
really like because it speaks to his
strong sense of martyrdom and
self-sacrifice but what still remains
unclear in the main game and even in all
of this cut content after all this time
I think is what gurmann hoped to achieve
in the hunter's dream and what he's
waiting for Lawrence to achieve in the
outside do you remember this line of
dialogue Oh Lawrence what's taking you
so long I've grown too old for this of
little use now I'm afraid that's not cut
content that's in the game Lawrence
first vicar and founder of the healing
church was supposed to do something in
the waking world while Herman was in the
dream the question is what and the
answer at least at one point might have
been ministration writer
DMC Redgrave who is one of the best
analysts of Blood Bones law once wrote
that gurmann is desperate for Lawrence
and the art of blood ministration to
find someone who can put an end to the
nightmare who can find a pale blood
strong enough to become immune to the
taint of the great ones so with the
revelation that gurmann might have been
waiting specifically for the effects of
Lawrence's blood ministration it appears
that Redgrave may well have been right
his pale blood hunt document will be the
first link in the description it's one
of the best resources on blood-borne
story to date as many of you already
know but to those of you who don't do
yourself a favor and
set aside a couple of hours to read it
all
of course there could be other reasons
Germann is waiting for the effects of
Lawrence's blood administration for
example Lawrence's beasts embrace rune
shows that he was trying to control the
scourge of beasts and maybe ministration
was a way of doing that and also the
metamorphosis Rudin also speaks of how
their discovery of blood made their
dream of evolution a reality
so perhaps gurmann was waiting for
ministration to achieve these things as
well but it's been used and I'm not sure
if we'll ever know for sure and as it
turns out the one who administers blood
to us in the opening cutscene originally
had more to him as well welcome weary
traveler to the great city of yharnam
the troubles you must have seen your
homeland plagued by a sickness for
spares fear you suffer your loved ones
suffer it's like a curse but there is
hope for you yet the blood used
administration of the trade of Yanam is
a special thing indeed the only thing
that can cure your sickness interesting
to note the mention of a plague
afflicted homeland outside of yharnam
and that blood was a trade of yharnam
suggesting that blood might have made
its way out of the city these things are
especially relevant if we're getting an
extension of this world in shadows died
twice and it seems also that you were
supposed to exchange a few lines of
dialogue with the minister after the
transfusion woken up with something of a
nightmare have you a foul murky story
quite beyond my own reckoning and there
be something to tell the grandkids hey
oh but I have nothing more to tell I
only show the way and the way has been
shown no it's in your hands until the
dang sweet mud takes us all
upon the awakening of her brightest upon
the awakening of Aubry Attis debri Otis
is fairly central to the story as it is
this great one who works together with
the choir looking to the skies in search
of astral signs which may lead them to
the rediscovery of true greatness as the
quote-unquote left behind great one it
seems that every Attis did not ascend
with her kin and so it's awakening might
have originally been more important to
the story anyway it also appears that
you could kill this Blood Minister if
you so desired revealing that yharnam
may well exist in a sort of pocket
dimension as expected my death that is
not
it's your nightmare after all but the
thing I want to talk about is that in
the cut content there's this common
theme of characters being far more aware
of the dreams that they actually reside
within I like the information this
provides because now we've heard German
muse about his capture within his
hunter's dream we've heard Mikkel ash
brag about his new real world and so too
do we hear Maria lament our progress
through the nightmare of the old hunters
hmm a visitor how unexpected
then the secrets of the church had been
laid bare good hunter lost in the
nightmare what did you think of that
beast the legend and those ailing Ward's
of the church I know what you did to
them it's not your fault
the nightmare held them and now they are
free this beastly legend she refers to
could be Ludwig or Lawrence though
Ludwig is closer and within her building
she mentions the ailing Ward's of the
church to which would have been her
patience in the research hall that you
killed up to this point interesting also
to note again that dying in a nightmare
is a way to be set free something that's
reinforced in the base game with my
collage
and with German be freed from the night
Maria then tries to coax us out of the
nightmare but what about you have you
profited at all if you answer yes she
commends you and she tries to gently
lure you out of the nightmare with yet
more profit to tide you over remember
Maria is likely here far more wilfully
than the other hunters cursed to remain
in this nightmare as there are signs
that she has a lot of guilt about what
the hunters did here in the fishing
hamlet so if you answer yes I have
profited from being here oh really well
that's a relief now you can leave this
nightmare have respect for the beast
hunter Gammons wishes besides you will
not find your enemies here take the
relics in this room as your parting
prize let them be your strength and
return to your hands good hunter it's so
curious that she says that gurmann
wouldn't want you to progress further
perhaps because the events here were
what led to his beloved Maria's death if
you answer no I haven't profited enough
from this nightmare her tone is far more
wary because basically you're saying
you're not satisfied and this indicates
you may well want more from this
nightmare I thought as much
nightmares and secrets they'll only get
you so far now you can leave this place
you could argue that a lot of this
dialogue is redundant but I love how
this flushes out her character and her
tone especially the bits where she says
good hunter like the doll yes it's cut
content but it's not the kind of cut
content that contradicts with what we
already know this was likely removed as
a stylistic choice as they probably
wanted the original cutscene to be
shorter and more punchy what's wrong my
hunter don't you hear the hunt calling
or do you wish to teach something more
from the depths of this nightmare
even if it means my murder hmm look at
you that glint in your eyes you girl are
insufferable oh I know very well how the
secrets beckon so sweetly only an honest
death will cure you now liberate you
from your wild curiosity and there's a
lot more dialog than this that I haven't
put in this video because I haven't got
around to extracting it yet but not only
that but you need to check out
everything in the description because
down there are videos by people capable
of extracting never-before-seen assets
and character models from the game as
well there has been some really amazing
work done in the last few weeks and it's
awesome the game this old can get so
much fresh blood so to speak you should
also check out the blood-borne remixes
by Alex Roy the perfectly tweaked
soundtrack which is a perfect backdrop
to this video about cut content I say
there's a lot but this description box
is full of some really good stuff so
don't neglect it patrons will get access
to my notes on the cut content that I
haven't mentioned in this video as a
thank you to everyone who's pledged to
the beacon tier and above but to lead us
out I'll pass over to Gascoigne whose
cut dialogue has interesting
implications for the next video which is
going to tie all of the souls born
storylines together
sea creature may you rest in peace
buzzer I'll see you soon
[Music]